michael bloomberg is jumping into the
race this is this is huge news this is
very significant it's it's it's really
great I think the great thing about
Bloomberg is that he's an old white
billionaire nanny-state gun grabber so
amazingly he checks nobody's boxes he
manages to be the exact opposite of what
almost everybody wants he manages to to
be precisely the thing that everybody on
all sides is not looking for and he's
like you know those games at the
carnival where it is they say everybody
wins and so you just have to throw a
ping-pong ball at like a in the
direction of 600 fish balls that are all
stacked next to each other and and of
course whatever prize you win it you
spend $2 on a ball whatever prize you
win is worth a lot less than $2 but
anyway Michael Bloomberg throws his
ping-pong ball at the fish balls and the
ball manages to bounce off of the rim of
every fish bowl and then landed a pond
50 yards away it's kind of amazing
it's almost impressive it's almost
impressive that somebody could manage to
have no constituency at all and that's
what Bloomberg pulls off so it's great
to have him in the race I'm pretty
impressed by that
speaking of billionaires there's been a
discussion recently about how much money
Bill Gates should be allowed to have of
his own speaking at a conference a few
days ago Gates said that he pays a lot
in taxes he pays
he said he's paid over 10 billion
dollars in taxes he says that's more
than anybody else in the country with it
which which which I would believe and
and he's fine with paying even more than
that he says but he doesn't like the tax
plans put forward by people like
Elizabeth Warren because he feels that
that she would want to confiscate way
more than is reasonable so his exact
words were I've paid over ten million
dollars in taxes I've paid more than
anyone in taxes if I had to pay 20
billion it's fine but when you say I
should pay a hundred billion then I'm
starting to do a little bit of math over
what I would have left over
now it seems reasonable to me right the
the guy doesn't want to pay a hundred
billion dollars in taxes pays ten
billion he says fine he says he'd do 20
billion honestly that'd be more generous
than I would be I I don't think I'd be
willing to pay 20 billion even if I had
100 billion but he says he doesn't want
to pay a hundred billion um
Warren responded by saying that she
wouldn't take a hundred billion very
generous of her although she doesn't say
how much she would take it'd be more
than ten she says not a hundred very
nice of her but Bernie Sanders of course
sensed an opportunity and he jumped in
too
he sets the opportunity to out socialist
Elizabeth Warren and who out class
warfare Elizabeth Warren and he sent a
tweet last night saying this was Bernie
Sanders say Bill Gates was actually
taxed a hundred billion dollars we could
end homelessness homelessness and
provide safe drinking water to everyone
in this country bill would still be a
multi billionaire our message the
billionaire class cannot have it all
when so many have so little okay a few
problems here and I say all of this as
someone who is not a Bill Gates fan I'm
not waving pom-poms for Bill Gates if I
were to list hundred people in the
country who I most admire Bill Gates
probably won't make the list but I also
don't think that I have a right to his
money as much as I would like it and
just like anyone else as jealous as I am
that's other people get to be
billionaires and I don't I mean I would
love to be a billionaire I'm not and I
know we're all very jealous about that
but but even if that's the case I don't
I don't have a right to his money so
here's the problem with Bernie's
approach aside from just how massively
stupid it is in general Sanders says
that we could end homelessness with a
hundred billion dollars
now what'd you think about that because
this is this is really the the mentality
of a child well we'll just give them all
money and the problem will be solved how
do you get rid of homelessness just give
them all money easy enough
no the majority of homeless people are
homeless either because of drugs or
mental illness or often both that that's
that is the thing that maybe not in
every case but in most cases if
somebody's living on the street it's
going to have a lot to do with one of
those factors or both now if you can't
solve that problem Addiction and Mental
Illness by throwing money at it which
you can't then I mean if someone's
addicted to heroin you can't just maybe
Bernie Sanders doesn't understand this
but if someone's addicted to heroin and
they're living on the street and you
walk up and say here's ten thousand
dollars
stop being addicted to heroin you that's
not only is that not going to work but
you probably have just killed that
person by doing that so if you can't
solve the problems of Addiction and
Mental Illness by throwing money at it
that means you can't solve homelessness
by throwing money at it this is it's
it's talking about solving homelessness
with a hundred billion dollars it's like
saying that you could solve anorexia and
eating disorders by just making sure
that everyone has enough food to eat
it just it completely misses the point
entirely
you're not understanding what the
problem is and your solution actually
would make the problem a whole lot worse
also second point here if a hundred
billion dollars could end homelessness
and give everyone safe drinking water
think about that No More homelessness
everyone has safe drinking water with a
hundred billion dollars now in theory I
think it's a
if it were if it was possible for the
government to End Homelessness
quote-unquote and make sure that
everyone has safe water to drink with a
hundred million dollars I would say yes
they should do that but here's the point
they wouldn't that doesn't that doesn't
mean they need to go and take a hundred
billion dollars from Bill Gates because
if they could do that with a hundred
billion dollars then they should have
already done it without Bill Gates's
money the government brings in four
trillion dollars a year four trillion
with a T that's almost 40 times Bill
Gates's net worth that they bring every
year so if a hundred billion dollars
could have those utopian results then
shouldn't we be living in Utopia right
now considering the four trillion
dollars they have at their disposal
should we be living in a literal Garden
of Eden at this point now you could try
to say well yeah they bring in all that
money but it's spent elsewhere there are
other things we need to spend it on and
that's why we need the extra a hundred
billion so we can go and solve
homelessness okay so you're telling me
there's four trillion dollars worth of
stuff for the government to spend money
on and all of it is more important than
ending homelessness and making sure
people have saved water a drink you're
telling me that it's possible to do both
of those things end homelessness make
sure everybody has safe drinking water
with 140th of the government's revenue
but they they just decide to allocate
the money elsewhere anyway
well isn't that a problem isn't it then
a
problem of allocation of resources not a
problem of a lack of resources to get
the job done either that or it's a
problem of the government just not
functionally having the ability to solve
those problems by dumping money on it
so either way taking another a hundred
bill from bill isn't gonna matter but
this is just a general a general point
every time someone like Bernie Sanders
or Elizabeth Warren starts talking about
all of the wonderful things they could
do if only they had an extra 50 billion
a hundred billion a year or whatever
we're not even a year I mean if they're
talking about cough you confiscate a
hundred billion from from you're not
gonna get a hundred billion from Bill
Gates every year that's just a one-time
deal because you take it almost all of
his money and so now you have it so
anytime you hear what these people say
okay if we just had this amount of money
we could do all these amazing things
well just keep in mind that they already
have four trillion a year just to throw
around and so if it were
Cybil to do those things they're talking
about they would have already done it
and besides all that the bigger point is
this and this maybe is the most
important point with Bernie Sanders
Elizabeth Warren it who are you to
decide what people should and shouldn't
have Bernie Sanders Bernie Sanders has
exact words our message the billionaire
class cannot have it all when so many
have so little okay but who are you
Bernie to decide what the billionaire
class can have why why should you get to
make that decision that's the question
that never gets answered by these people
I mean they could stand up there and
talk all they want about how evil and
greedy the billionaires are and maybe
they are maybe they are evil and greedy
yeah I don't know it doesn't matter the
point is who if you're saying oh yeah
nobody needs that much money okay well
how much money do they need what's the
cutoff okay you've decided that once you
get to X amount of money that's too much
you don't need that much well what is
the cutoff what is the X amount of money
and how did you decide that
and who in
Howard you to be the one to decide that
but all it all seems very arbitrary to
me and why should you be the one to
decide that okay um back to Warren for a
moment here so sorry about that we have
to go go back to Elizabeth Warren but
Warren secured a big endorsement
yesterday I want to acknowledge it you
know I think it'd only be fair to do
that she was endorsed by the
organization black women for that's for
fo r and women spelled with an X women
so WOM X end which would really be
pronounced I guess women women so she
was endorsed by the organization black
women for and they came out and endorsed
her for president and Warren responded
by saying thank you black women for
black this is what she says black trans
and Syst women gender non-conforming and
non-binary people are the backbone of
our democracy and I don't take this
endorsement lightly I'm committed to
fighting alongside you for the big
structural change our country needs the
backbone of our democracy non-binary
people are the backbone of our democracy
first of all that's a lot of work for
fourteen people to do your to put make
them the backbone that that's your you
know that's having them hold up
democracy like that that's that's that's
that's a lot of weight you're putting on
just fourteen people's shoulders but
what by the way why are black women
getting lumped in with non-binary and
gender non-conforming people now this
this particular organization that's what
they do so that that's that's why
Elizabeth Warren brought it up but the
question still stands what
how are those groups even related and
isn't it kind of insulting to you know
equate their identity with some passing
fad like gender non-conforming
and it would it be like if someone said
I appreciate the support of American
Catholics and Star Trek fans what what
are those two have to do with each other
I mean it's possible that someone could
be a Star Trek fan and a Catholic you
know I'm Catholic and I kind of like a
certainly Star Trek is better than Star
Wars at the very least which isn't hard
to do but do you really think those two
identities are on the same level are
just as important carry the same
importance as is that really how you see
it but anyway here but this is this is
what the left does where they take all
of these various identities and they
lump them all in a pile together and act
as though they're all equally as
legitimate so you have something like
black women okay well that makes sense
you know there's an identity that has to
do with someone's race their sex their
actual biological sex okay that makes
sense but then into that same category
you're putting stuff like non-binary
gender non-conforming and it's I think
it's it's insulting and demeaning on top
of everything else but this is just
turbocharged pandering here that warren
is doing and it's the kind of thing I
mean I always say it but it is the left
is beyond parity at this point a
statement like non-binary people are the
backbone of our democracy that's the
kind of thing that I would say
sarcastically that's the kind of thing I
would say if I was trying to you know
satirize the left but they're becoming
increasingly difficult to satirize
because in order to do good satire or
good parody yes whatever whatever you're
trying to satirize you're taking it to
in a sort of absurd extreme to try to
highlight the flaws with the
thing that your satirizing but it's it's
becoming difficult to take it to a more
absurd extreme than these people will
already take it themselves ok so moving
on jeff goldblum they're now trying to
cancel Jeff Goldblum Goldblum if
Goldblum gets cancelled then I truly
no-one is save a t-rex couldn't even
cancel Jeff Goldblum but now the the
woke mob is trying to because of
something Goldblum said in an interview
this is what he said and I'm just
looking at this now for the first time
so we'll see if this is if this is if
this justifies him getting cancelled
Jeff Goldblum has said that and I'm
reading now from the independent Jeff
Goldblum has said he thinks there's a
presumption of innocence until proven
guilty regarding Woody Allen and the
sexual abuse allegations made against
him Allen was accused of child
molestation by his daughter Dylan Farrow
he was also he has also always denied
any abuse since the allegations came to
light numerous Hollywood figures
included Colin Firth and Greta Gerwig
have pledged never to make a film with
Allen again in a new interview with the
eye paper Goldblum has said he would
quote consider working with the director
in the future having had a minor role in
his 1977 felt film Annie Hall I think
there is a presumption of innocence
until proven guilty said Goldblum I know
I enjoyed working with him many years
ago and I sat in with his band once too
okay that's it that's what he said
that's all he said innocent until proven
guilty and people are upset by this in
fact the very first
since Jeff Goldblum has said he thinks
there's a presumption of innocence well
isn't there though now I happen to think
that Woody Allen is a creep but I don't
aye aye sir if what he Allen came
knocking on my door and asking me to
appear in one of his films I would
probably have to turn him down even if
that's unlikely to happen but what
exactly is the problem here I think
there's a presumption of innocence until
proven guilty okay yes that is a that's
a that's a an idea that is very much a
cornerstone of our system and our
democracy innocent until proven guilty
and it's pretty disturbing now and you
have people that are basically in
principle coming out against innocent
until proven guilty where it's now it's
now controversial and if you get you
cancelled to to say that to say innocent
until proven guilty those are these are
scary times we live in all right before
we get to emails one other thing if
you've been paying attention online the
trend now is this okay boomer meme I
don't know if you're not on Twitter I
don't know if this is bled outside of
Twitter or not or if it's just a Twitter
thing but on Twitter this is the the
trend now where you say okay boomer and
you know anytime someone who's older
makes a point that everyone everyone
else feels is out of touch then you just
respond with okay boomer well boomers I
guess don't like this and so there's
been this slate of articles and tweets
and things from boomers who are reacting
to the okay boomer meme in ways that
only show how out of touch they are and
just elicit more okay boomers and maybe
the worst example of this was a guy a
radio host who said a few days ago he
tweeted that he compared the word boomer
now to the n-word saying that it's a
slur basically to say
he said boomer is the n-word of ageism
being hip and flipped does not make
bigotry okay nor is a derisively because
it's new so just the word boomer is now
a derisively comparable to the n-word
and of course he tweets this and then
what happens there's 50 million people
responding with okay boomer because of
course that's gonna happen the only
thing I want to say is it seems like
there's finally a real generational
warfare ramping up with Millennials and
Gen Z going after boomers and yeah I'm
kind of enjoying it I have to be honest
I think we were due for a good
generational war
well here's what I'll say a couple of
things first of all I don't mean to get
into a you started it type of thing but
with the boomers you did kind of start
it because it seems to me that for the
last ten years it's it's been perfectly
acceptable to insult Millennials and to
complain about Millennials and boomers
did that all the time
and I've done it too there's plenty of
things to criticize about us don't get
me wrong but that was a perfectly
acceptable thing to do for the last
decade and now just really just recently
I think Millennials have been starting
to throw it back in the direction of
boomers and now all of a sudden now all
of a sudden it's a problem well how dare
you lump an entire gym how dare you
criticize an entire generation and make
these generalities like this isn't that
what you've been doing with Millennials
this whole time so now it's a problem
that's an issue for me also the other
thing is when you get into the
generational war the issue that boomers
are gonna run into is that you can't
really and this is what I've been saying
for the last several years with boomers
criticizing and complaining about
malaise
you can't really criticize a millennial
as a Boomer without criticizing yourself
because they're your kids you're the one
who raised these people and so they're
there I think there has been in the
boomer generation and again we're
speaking generally but in the boomer
generation there has been I think in
some ways a failure to confront their
own failures especially when it comes to
parenting and to acknowledge that hey
you know if the millennial generation
really is terrible
like we say that's on us because we're
the ones who raise these people so
that's probably our Father it seems like
we may have screwed up big time in the
parenting apartment but that that
there's very little acknowledgment of
that which is kind of annoying not to
mention of course boomers bankrupted the
country drove up massive debts destroyed
the institution of marriage and the
family started a bunch of pointless war
so on and so there are other things too
there are other things that maybe should
cause should be reason to pause and have
a little bit of self-reflection and
maybe acknowledge that hey you know we
we kind of screwed up in a few areas and
we're sort of leaving you a country
that's not in great shape and we're
leaving you a lot of problems to fix and
we're sorry about that
that's all I think maybe if you want to
stop the okay boomer meme maybe that's
all just I think boomers may just need
to say that listen we screwed up you
know we're we're kind of on our way out
and you're taking over the country and
it's and we're not you know we're
handing you the keys to the car and it's
pretty dinged up and our bad sorry about
that
actually the keys the car's not dinged
up it is on fire as we speak we are
handing you a car that is on fire here
are the keys sorry about that
okay let's go to emails Matt wall show
at gmail.com Matt wall show at gmail.com
this is from Stephen says hey Matt this
is Stephen today on your podcast you
mentioned that the school system is
geared mostly towards girls and you also
noted that many boys in our school
system are hopped on drugs because they
have too much energy or can't focus
they're put on drugs because of their
energy yeah I was curious as to how you
think the school system could be better
geared towards both genders well the
problem Stephan is that it in order to
gear the school system towards both
genders you would need to rework it from
the bottom up you would need to tear the
whole thing down and basically start
over and I don't think as long as we're
going to have this massive education
system this government-run system where
you've got you know millions of kids in
the system and they're going to these
schools and they're in classrooms with
35 other kids as long as we're doing
that there's not gonna be any way to
gear the system towards each of them
individually you got 35 kids in a
classroom there's there's there's no way
to do it you can't gear you cannot
personalize education when you're doing
that there's no way that for the
teachers to do it and it's not the
teachers fault so what ends up happening
is because you've got all these kids in
the system and just with the way that it
works you know you put them in you got a
bunch of kids in a class and they're in
this class for 45 minutes and they go to
the next class and on and on and then
they leave and because of that the
system has to streamline and it's
inevitable that the system is going to
run on just memorization and
regurgitation and you got to be able to
sit still and and fill out paperwork and
remember things and then repeat them on
to a sheet of paper and and that's how
it's going to work
and that is a lot easier for girls than
it is for boys that's just a fact boys
have a lot more physical energy they
have they have a harder time paying
attention in that kind of environment
they're not as good at memorization as
girls are so my point is if you're
looking for the school system to be able
to personalize and gear the educational
environment and the educational
experience to the personal needs of each
kid that isn't gonna happen but I do
think that education needs to be
personalized and needs to be geared
towards the personal needs of every
individual kid which means that I think
the best thing is to not put your kids
in that system to begin with that's why
I think homeschooling is great or you
know there are not every private school
is great but there are private schools
that are much smaller and and are able
to do that at least do it much more than
the public schools can so I think that's
that's the answer the answer is to
withdraw from this system as much and I
know not everybody can but as much as
possible to withdraw from this system
and to give our kids an education that
is tailored to their specific needs this
from Caleb says hey Matt I appreciate
your views on relationships and more
broadly morality I've been a listener
since the start of this year and have
come to value the wisdom and dry humor
you consistently share I was hoping you
could help me with an issue I've been
having I'm 22 and I've been dating this
girl for almost a year now a couple
weeks ago she said she loved me there
was an awkward moment as I couldn't make
myself say it back we talked about it
afterwards and came to an understanding
my question is that I don't think I will
ever say that to her and I feel and feel
like I mean it when I think of my future
I don't ever really consider her a part
of it I don't want to hurt her and I
feel like a horrible person for letting
this happen what should I do
thank you for your time well Caleb first
of all good for you for not saying I
love you back if he didn't mean it I
think most people probably would have
said it back to be nice thereby leading
the other person on and making the
situation worse
I think I would commend you for that as
for what you should do now I think you
you probably know what you should do and
in a relationship like this when you're
dating the moment you start asking
questions like this that's probably a
good sign that you already know what you
should do which is to end the
relationship if you've been with this
girl for a year you're 22 you don't love
her you don't see her you don't see her
in your future that means that there's
no reason for this relationship to
continue dating someone when you know
there is no future is pointless it's
just it's just building up heartache for
the future it's like going on a long
road trip knowing ahead of time that
your car is going to break down on the
side of the road before you get to your
destination so the further you go the
worse it's gonna be when the car breaks
down so why not if you know it's gonna
happen why not pull over now take
control the situation I think this is
especially the case when the other
person your girlfriend in this case
obviously thinks that it is headed
somewhere so she has intentions for your
relationship that you don't have and so
I think it's your responsibility to just
tell her that break it off it'll hurt
it'll be painful
it'll be kind of miserable for a while
so will she but it gets better a lot
faster then you think it will and then
you'll and you'll be glad before you
know you'll be glad that you broke it
off when you did both for her sake and
for yours okay um let's see another
another relationship one this is a
because I'm putting on my doctor love
hat here this is from cam says dear Matt
I've been a fan of your work for the
last five years I'm writing because I
really value your insight and opinion I
think maybe other people my age could
benefit from this question too I'm 27
and recently started dating a man who
checks all of the most important boxes
I've been hoping and praying for he's a
Christian we aligned on politics hobbies
worldview maturity humor communication
he's everything I could want in a
husband and I can imagine building a
life together the only doubt I'm facing
is that I don't feel the same excitement
and infatuation that I felt in past
relationships is this a sign that
something important is missing from the
relationship I feel affectionate towards
him and I'm attracted to him but it's
not the head-over-heels effect in fact
it's more more the opposite I feel calm
secure and happy and a little nervous at
the same time at the thought of
committing to each other forever can you
have a long happy successful marriage
with someone if it starts off without
figurative fireworks what do you think
also was there a point in your courtship
that you knew you were going to marry
your wife sincere thanks for all you do
and may God bless you well if you hadn't
cam if you hadn't included that
paragraph where you said that you feel
it calm secure and happy if you hadn't
said that then I would say it's probably
not a good sign because yes
relationships are not all about feelings
and love is not just a feeling it's a
choice it's an act of an act of will
it's a choice to sacrifice for another
person that's that's what love is but
you should still there should still be
feelings there and if you just feel
nothing for somebody from the very
beginning well that's not not not a good
foot to begin on but you say that you
feel calm secure and happy and I would
say that that's in your affectionate
feel fection towards them and you're
attracted and on top of that you align
on politics hobbies worldview maturity
humor communication I look you have to
make decision for yourself but to me
that sounds like a keeper and as far as
not having that infatuation feeling well
you talk about a fashion that's really
sort of the obsession that people have
and I think the fact that you don't have
that it's probably just more a sign of
you're older and so if you compare this
and I don't think you said how old you
are you said you're 27 okay so if you
compare this relationship maybe to when
you were 16 and dating someone
yeah it's you're not gonna have it's not
gonna be the same quote fireworks that
you're talking about because when you
were sick
tene being emotionally immature you were
just obsessed with the other person and
of course it didn't last for very long
and you had this obsession and then it
quickly faded away and the relationship
died that's how it goes when you're 16
years old but as you get older it's you
don't you're not gonna be obsessed with
you which is good because to have it to
be married to someone and be obsessed
with them and you want to be around them
24/7 and you can't be away from them
ever that would you you you couldn't
function that way it'd be very weird way
to have a marriage and it would get
pretty exhausting pretty quick so this
thing you're talking about a feeling
calm secure happy I think that's a sign
it's not a it's not a bad sign and it's
not even it's not a certainly a bad sign
about this guy I think that's just a
sign of your own maturity and the fact
that you're looking for something deeper
and stronger and more solid and it
sounds like you found it okay finally
this is from Shane says Matt not really
a question just the remark on how you
said David full conflic and then
remarked that it's a dangerous name to
say on the air and then proceeded to say
his name eight times in a row I know you
really disregarded the left's outrage
mob but wow that was bold almost as bold
as people who say Epstein didn't kill
himself which he most definitely did
your friend David full conflic yeah well
David feau conflic is just I think one
of the best reporters out there and
that's what it comes down to the thing
about David Falcon flick
I'd say that folk and flicks best
attribute the main point about fall
conflict that I would make about Falcon
flick is that fokin flick he's just he's
true to himself you know I'm saying
there aren't many Falken flicks out
there there's folk and flick and then
there's not focus like you know what I'm
saying it's it but Falcon flick is the
only fault and you got to love
Foca flick that's that's that's that's
really also thank you for giving me the
chance to talk about my favorite
reporter David Falcon flick again and
thanks everyone for watching we'll leave
it there I think have a great weekend
and Godspeed
the Matt Walsh show is produced by Sean
Hampton executive producer Jeremy boring
senior producer Jonathan hey supervising
producer Mathis Glover supervising
producer Robert Stirling technical
producer Austin Stephens editor Donovan
Fowler audio mixer Mike Cora Mina the
Matt Walsh show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire 20 19 if
you prefer facts over feelings aren't
offended by the brutal truth and you can
still laugh at the insanity filling our
national news cycle well tune in to the
Ben Shapiro show we'll get a whole lot
of that and much more see you there